I still believe in
Heroes
[Music]
seees we found you made you one of us
not as strong as you think I know
renegate so do want to see one where you
going to kill Thanos
Avengers the
annihilator you took everything from me
now I'm returning the
favor she's targeting the people that I
care
about from every place I call
home she's trying to start a
war what are you prepared to
do give her help watch
me the Marvels read PG13 in theaters
November 10 get tickets now
Captain
Marvel we need
Heroes hire further faster baby that's
right we need you buckle up
folks I like this one she is
incredible oh
yeah
oh my God here we
go higher
further
[Music]
faster